while all sporting events have been
canceled in the US since last weekend
the International Olympic Committee has
been watching and waiting to decide how
to handle the planned
Tokyo game set to begin July 24th the
Summer Olympics have been canceled three
times before in 1916 1940 and 1944 in
each case that was because of war
countries have also cancelled their
involvement to make a statement
including exactly 40 years ago today
some saying that Soviet forces now are
in complete control of all major towns
and highways it was the Soviet Union's
first land grab since the end of World
War two and reaction was swift inside
Afghanistan rebels went to war against a
hundred thousand Soviet soldiers outside
diplomats and dissidents began their own
battle I've sent a message today to the
United States Olympic Committee On
January 20th 1980 President Jimmy Carter
made his position clear that unless the
Soviets withdraw their troops within a
month from Afghanistan that the Olympic
Games be moved from Moscow to an
alternate site or multiple sites or
postponed or canceled the idea for an
Olympic boycott gained widespread
attention when a Russian nuclear
scientists turned activists named Andrei
Sakharov endorsed it with Soviet
invading forces in Afghanistan these are
the American people nor I will support
sending an Olympic team to Moscow where
you coming from this time
President Carter sent Muhammad Ali to
Kenya Tanzania Senegal and Nigeria to
convince other nations to join a boycott
but the American public was split some
Olympians believe the games should
transcend politics many of the athletes
in track and field and definitely me
have gotten the impression that hey
maybe we were being used a small pawns
and big game and don't like that when
the Soviets did not leave by Carter's
deadline day the president made the
boycott official I can't say at this
moment other nations will not go to the
Summer Olympics in Moscow ours will not
go it was joined by 65 other countries
including China Iran Israel and West
Germany though 80 other nations competed
in Moscow including Britain Spain Italy
and France
the Soviets staged a counter protest in
1984 setting out the Olympic Games in
Los Angeles all the while the war in
Afghanistan raged on Russians didn't
leave until 1989 a disastrous nine-year
effort that left up to two million dead
and many more displaced so now us
swimming has basically said they'd like
to see the games postponed at this point
but right now America's Olympic
governing body is saying hold hold on
yeah just wait and see what happens so
this looming governing body sent a note
letter and basically said we'd like to
postpone but what the overall implicit
is saying right now is we need to watch
things because there are athletes we
thought their athletes do want to
compete just because one side believes
it should be called off doesn't mean
everyone does so let's watch and see
where things stand later because the
question is if there is a postponement
or whatever it you got to decide whether
it's a monthien try to start in August
or you wait a year you have to train and
qualify and do all of that